[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
qui ne s'est jamais posé cette question
qu'est ce que je ferais si je gagnais au
loto alors statistiquement ce soir dans
cette salle deux tiers d'entre vous a
déjà joué à l'inde au jeu et rêvait
peut-être de devenir un grand gagnant
d'ailleurs si vous avez tenté votre
chance pour le tirage loto de ce soir
peut-être que l'un d'entre vous
m'appellera demain puisque mon métier
consiste à remettre leurs gains aux
gagnants à partir de 1 million d'euros
être présent à leurs côtés le jour j et
les jours d'après mon équipe et moi même
avons la chance de rencontrer chaque
semaine quatre nouveaux millionnaires
quatre nouveaux millionnaires chaque
semaine c'est à dire 200 nouveaux
millionnaires parents d'être à leurs
côtés pour la remise du gain le jour j
et les jours d'après de les accompagner
sur cette subtile alchimie entre plaisir
et bonheur de cela nous sommes les
témoins privilégiés les éveilleurs
parfois les confidents très souvent quel
événement extraordinaire que le gain
c'est un événement hors du commun unique
singulier moi j'en ai pris vraiment
conscience la première fois que j'ai
remis un chèque à des gagnants
s'agissait d'un couple de jeunes
retraités
vous avez gagné 5 millions d'euros au
loto et pour l'occasion il était
accompagné d'un de leur fils qui est
militaire
il avait fait des missions en
afghanistan au mali on peut donc penser
que ses capacités de résistance
psychique et émotionnelle était éprouvé
et pourtant quand j'ai tendu le chèque à
ses parents je l' ai vu fondre en larmes
littéralement submergé par l'émotion
je me suis rendu compte à ce moment là
même si je le savais déjà à quel point
cet événement et est hors du commun
alors vous vous demandez peut-être
qu'ils sont ces gagnants mais c'est vous
c'est nous
ils sont représentatifs de la population
française ils vivent à dijon à paris à
fort de france à bayonne ils sont
ouvriers architectes commerçants sans
emplois retraités professeur catherine
par exemple était agent immobilier alors
ce soir j'ai modifié volontairement les
prénoms des gagnants que j'évoquerai par
respect pour l'heure anonyme dont
catherine vous disais j'étais agent
immobilier lorsqu'elle a gagné 2
millions d'euros au loto
elle a ignoré ce gain elle ne voulait
pas que sa vie change
elle ne voulait pas que sa vie change
elle avait peur que ça bouscule un
équilibre qu'elle aimait et puis petit à
petit elle a apprivoisé seguin dans un
coin de sa tête
elle avait toujours eu envie de
travailler dans le bien-être
aujourd'hui elle est aromathérapeute
elle adore son métier elle s'y
retrouvent totalement gagné au loto lui
a permis d'accélérer ça a été un
tremplin vers cette vie professionnelle
dont elle rêvait mais qu'elle nous est
peut-être pas s'avouer d'ailleurs pour
l'anecdote je retrouve catherine dans
quelques jours puisqu'elle va venir a
animé une session lors d'un atelier que
nous proposons à nos grands gagnants sur
son expérience de développement
personnel de reconversion on vient de le
voir le gain peut être déstabilisant
c'est vrai parce que c'est un changement
et comme dans tout changement on perd
des choses et on en gagne d'autres
quand on est un gagnant du loto on gagne
beaucoup mais mais il ya des doutes qui
peuvent surgir
ça peut être déstabilisant il ya des
nouvelles questions qui se font jour
est-ce que je vais changer est ce que ma
vie va devenir plus compliqué est-ce que
je vais perdre des amis
et si j'en parle pas est ce que le
secret va pas être trop lourd à porter
toutes ces questions elles sont
légitimes
c'est vrai
que dans certains cas quelques fois des
situations peuvent se complexifier des
relations peuvent se détériorer
c'est pas le fait du gain cd situation
qui existait le gain n'est qu'un effet
loupe amplificateur mai mais cela peut
ça peut arriver
je vous rassure tout ça est transitoire
et jusqu'à présent personne ne nous a
jamais rendu lé chèque
donc ça se passe plutôt très bien et
puis chacun réagit différemment face à
ce gain en fonction de de son milieu
social de son éducation de ces valeurs
ont réagi de manière différente et puis
il ya aussi tout le poids de l'héritage
judéo-chrétien qui fait que cet argent
n'est pas le fruit du travail et
certains peuvent ressentir une certaine
culpabilité
avec ce lien je pense juste maintenant à
dominique épaules qui ont gagné 7
millions d'euros il ya dix ans dominique
épaules avait de très belles situations
une certaine aisance financière
on pouvait légitimement penser que voilà
il allait se fondre dans cette dans
cette vie très très facilement c'est le
cas aujourd'hui
mais au début ils ont vraiment eu besoin
de notre accompagnement besoin qu'on
soit là à leurs côtés besoin de
rencontrer des gens qui avaient vécu la
même chose qu'eux alors aujourd'hui ils
sont totalement épanouie sont des
épicuriens et voyage beaucoup 6 à 8 mois
de l'année ils ont ils ne travaillent
plus mais au début ils avaient besoin
qu'on soit qu'on soit à leurs côtés et
ce qui est amusant dans le dans le cas
de dominique épaules c'est que
aujourd'hui ils sont devenus des
parrains pour les nouveaux gagnants
salle aura tellement apporté 7,7 cette
période cet accompagnement on était à
leurs côtés qu'ils ont souhaité
transmettre à leur tour la même chose
aux nouveaux gagnants et ça nous a
d'ailleurs inspiré un tout nouveau
service qu'on propose aujourd'hui à nos
gagnants qui est un cercle de parent
d'anciens gagnants qui accompagne qui
partagent leurs expériences avec les
nouveaux il ya des amitiés très forte
qui se nouent des liens vraiment
privilégiés qui se tissent entre eux et
pour nous c'est très émouvant
de d'assister à tout cela alors
finalement à quoi ressemble le jour
d'après et le jour d'après il est
différent pour chacun il est différent
pour chacun donc nous nous accompagnons
ce jour d'après avec un accompagnement
sur mesure et individuelles au moment du
gain puis un accompagnement collectif
pendant cinq ans après le gain sur deux
axes l'acce financiers et l'accès humain
tout ça dans la sphère du développement
personnel et ce qui nous tient vraiment
à coeur
ce qu'on a envie de transmettre à nos
gagnants c'est de réussir cette
transition entre plaisir et bonheur
alors certains scientifiques pensent que
le plaisir est l'ennemi du bonheur c'est
les hormones notamment qui pourrait être
en cause
la dopamine pour le plaisir la
sérotonine pour le bonheur et
l'accumulation plaisir pourraient
contrevenir au fait de pouvoir
construire son bonheur ça me rappelle
alexandre alexandre elle a gagné 8
millions d'euros il ya quelques années
la première année ils étaient dans le
plaisir
il a décidé de faire le tour du monde
d'offrir des cadeaux à ses amis de
s'acheter de belles voitures de sport il
était vraiment dans le dans le plaisir
et puis un jour il s'est dit que
peut-être l'essentiel était ailleurs et
il a eu envie d'ouvrir un restaurant
et aujourd'hui quand on revoit alexandre
il nous confie à quel point il est
heureux de se lever chaque matin de
préparer la cuisine est dans le partage
avec les clients de son restaurant il a
vraiment trouvé son bonheur durable et
c'est important aussi c'est ce qu'on
essaye d'expliquer et de transmettre à
nos gagnants le gain n'est pas une
finalité il doit s'inscrire dans une
dynamique de projet et chacun trouve le
sens qu'il veut qui lui ressemble à son
gain
lussier jacques par exemple ça fait dix
ans dix ans qu'ils offrent la cantine
scolaire aux enfants de leur commune
d'autres ont eu envie de soutenir le
club de basket de la ville
d'autres encore ont eu le souhait de
bâtir une fondation pour soutenir le
patrimoine culturel de leur région
et puis pour d'autres encore toute leur
énergie
ils vont la mettre à transmettre un
patrimoine à leurs enfants à leurs
petits enfants
si le sens qu'ils vont mettre à ce gars
donc le sens il ressemble à chacun et
chacun le conçois comme il l'entend par
contre il ya une chose sur lequel tous
les gagnants s'accordent absolument tous
la plus grande des richesses qu'ils ont
trouvé c'est une richesse immatérielle
grâce aux gains
c'est de la liberté c'est du temps pour
soi et pour les autres c'est de lattes
et sérénité c'est de la confiance en soi
et ça absolument tous nous le confie et
s'accordent sur ce point la richesse
immatérielle
c'est la plus belle chose qu'ils ont
trouvé en gagnant au loto ou à l'euro
millions alors en ce moment même
peut-être que vous êtes en train de vous
poser cette question et de vous dire
mais qu'est ce que je ferais si je
gagnais au loto alors vous savez que
c'est un événement qui peut être
déstabilisant c'est aussi une aventure
humaine et émotionnelle absolument hors
du commun exaltante
peut-être que certains d'entre vous sont
déjà en train d'imaginer la manière dont
ils conjuguerait plaisir et bonheur et
puis comment ils vivraient 7
cette richesse immatérielle moi je
souhaite de tout coeur qu'on puisse
poursuivre ensemble cette discussion que
vous m'appeliez un jour que vous soyez
grand gagnant est qu'on puisse
poursuivre cette discussion ensemble
mais rassurons nous rassurons nous le
bonheur demeure un chemin pers
neil et il ne tient qu'à nous à chacun
de nous de l'entretenir
chaque jour merci pour votre attention
[Applaudissements]